joining a show like this is clearly you
know just I'm not let's turn those
smiles to the upside down positions The
Stranger Things series is full of ultra
dramatic moments and for the actors
these scenes were as hard to film for
them as it was for us to watch them so
when things just got a little too far
for some of the cast the tears just
wouldn't stop flowing number one let's
face it wouldn't we all cry effectna was
about to take our souls to the upside
down well poor Millie Bobby Brown had to
film a lot of scenes with this creature
and it never got easier for her but
since she burst into tears the whole
rehearsal I was crying especially
considering her and Jamie Campbell Bauer
are best buds she refused to believe the
kind and warm-hearted Jaime was under
those horrific Prosthetics and she was
like that's not Jamie because I know
Jamie's dead like it's Justin it's just
Becca but all the acting in the world
couldn't fool a true friend those tears
are real ones only because this acting
was just too good for her to get past
Bower recalls Millie's words saying I
knew it was you when I could smell
cigarettes
number two vecina just loves making
teenagers cry and for Sadie sink she got
her tears in the form of physical
exhaustion production put so much work
into that escape from the upside down
scene layering the floor with fake blood
and other slippery substances it's
definitely scary and like it feels real
like the stakes are really high the
actress gave it her all even through
multiple takes but all that physical
exhaustion caused her to cry a lot she's
certainly maxed out her physical
potential in this Scene It was not like
the easiest set to film on but I mean it
looks amazing number three here's a
moment when the audiences and actors
emotions collided I think it's my year
Henderson
it seemed like Joe Quinn's time as Eddie
was gone in a Flash and a sudden
departure like that will make anyone
emotional fast on Joe's last day of
filming all the tears came flooding in
he recalls I had a shot of tequila in
the camera truck and I went home and
cried my eyes out he had made a family
out of that group and his time just
seemed over way too quickly number four
having an intensely emotional scene with
another actor can sometimes hit you hard
but being that Noah schnapp and Finn
wolfhard basically watched each other
grow up a car ride heart to heart was a
little too much to bear for them I think
she'd rather just get it over with quick
like ripping off a Band-Aid
this scene reportedly took the boys
about a day of filming and the more they
marinated in those emotional topics the
more emotional they got off camera we've
said it before and we'll say it again if
will or Mike goes we all go number five
oh teenagers sometimes you just gotta
deal with their Sinister sides
once again and more times to come we
find hour 11 being embarrassed in front
of a whole group of them Millie's proved
her acting chops here but were all her
emotions fake those tears were all
genuine and she really felt the
embarrassment of her character it was so
bad that even though a schnapp couldn't
hold his emotions in is it bad we were
all encouraging 11 at the end of the
scene number six we've watched Dustin
grow into the Fearless Demi Gorgon
Slayer we all know and love and at the
end of season 4 he faces his truest test
of emotion
I love you there
the death of Eddie was a tough one for
Dustin and the loss of Joe Quinn from
the cast was an even harder moment to
process for Gayton Matarazzo the best
acting comes from the most sincerest of
emotions that's exactly why his crying
was so authentic number seven like Joe
Jamie Campbell Bower was not ready to
let vechna go on the last filming day of
vechna Jaime was overcome with emotion
crying in front of the cast and crew
while still in his Prosthetics
though we can't imagine anyone hugged
him while in the slimy suit maybe they
waited till after they could at least
see his face number eight Papa Don't
Preach 11's not forgiving you all jokes
aside this scene was sad we guess we
mostly just feel sorry for 11 to be
honest but for Millie and Matthew Modine
this scene was very emotional to film it
felt to them like the end of a
friendship even though their
relationship on screen was quite hectic
this is the conclusion of that
relationship and she's not forgiving him
but they took a lengthy walk together
right before to be sure to say their
proper farewells number nine we're
honestly glad we weren't the only ones
balling our eyes out here basically
anytime Millie cries or through but to
pair that with an emotional letter from
Hopper forget about it and when life
hurts you
remember the heart
we aren't sure as to whether or not
brown knew of Hopper's true fate at the
end of season 3 but according to Millie
those tears were all too real for her
she listened to David Harbor's voice in
real time on set and just couldn't keep
it together number 10 Billy has a way of
making people cry so much so that some
of the kids couldn't contain their
emotions daker Montgomery was always
known to take things to the utmost
extreme on set and this scene in the
sauna proved to be a little too much for
the teen actors in The Final Cut of the
episode as eleven collapses into Mike's
arms Millie's exhaustion is not as much
acting as we'd like to think she cried
from those intense moments confusing
Finn wolfhard so much that he looked off
camera at the director for guidance
number 11. this one's a freebie for Noah
schnapp just because he has a pretty
good excuse for crying in season two
when will is basically possessed the
entire time Noah had to put in some not
so comfortable eye contacts this cost
his poor eyes to turn red and produce a
lot of Tears it's got to be a rough time
having to wear contacts during long
shoot days so we'll just give schnapp an
excuse on this one number 12. one
breakup is hard enough but try feeling
the Heartbreak multiple times on screen
or not this was a very tough experience
for Joe Curie in season two when Nancy
breaks Steve's heart we Guess The Duffer
Brothers really wanted a lot of shots
because Joe went home a lot of times
crying he just became too attached to
his character that those on-screen
heartbreaks with Nancy made it feel real
to him number 13 with the PowerHouse
acting Duo like Millie Bobby Brown and
David Harbor one can expect to have the
most intense emotions in a scene as we
see their arguments peak in season two
it was reported that brown and harbor
took these arguments offset tears and
all it's personal and that you get to
explore parts of your psyche of course
those were just the aftermath of filming
long days and detaching from those
scenes so we're sure everything is
father-daughter love now number 14 for
all of you binge Watchers out there you
did not experience the full Cliffhanger
of Hopper's feet even the end credit
scene in the finale of season three
still left out a lot of open-ended
uncertainty we're sure when Noah Ryder
knew of Hopper's return but she also
knew she had to sell his almost death
scene for the audience Ryder tapped into
her tear tap and certainly fooled us for
a long time number 15 like all actors
who meet their fate on Stranger Things
daker Montgomery could not handle
leaving his new found family with one of
the most intense endings in a series
finale Billy's character comes full
circle sacrificing himself to save the
others daker loathe this day would come
for Billy and although sad emotions came
flooding in after the director yelled
cut it's great to know that we weren't
the only ones bawling our eyes out
during well every season of stranger
things we are worried though that season
5 will produce a little more than a
couple tiers for the cast just know we
are all crying in this together was
there a scene in stranger things that
you just couldn't watch because it was
too emotional let us know in the
comments
[Music]